buddy welcome to the Development
Committee 14th of December 2017 for
usually emergency evacuation
announcement should we be requested to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the nearest
available exit to the chamber our
assembly point will be in the public car
park at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that this meeting won't be
all day we recorded and if you have a
phone please ensure it's on silent thank
you right apologies for absence have
been received in the office from Council
Steptoe who's been substituted by
council cup more counts lemare on who's
been substituted by councillor Hazelwood
there aren't any more we're all here so
non-members attending thank you we've
got councillors Ward looks Gale Hughes
and hoi mr. Hoyt okay item four minutes
of the meeting held on 23rd of November
no 2017 are you happy for me to sign
those as a correct and accurate record
of that meeting thank you item 5
declarations of interest Thank You
chairman yea non-pecuniary interest on
item 6 I'm a member of the airport
liaison committee and Ward and parish
councillor and then items 9 and 10 being
a ward and parish councillor thank you
Thank You mr. McCoy
yeah I just wanted to ask Angela law
we've I've got declare an interesting
item six as my sister-in-law works for
the airport
no that's the Stanley thank you
that's not quite clear an interest as
being a member of great worker and
parish council to do with item number
eight but I'm not on the development
committee at the parish just before we
get oh okay council Lucas girl Thank You
chairman non-pecuniary interest in item
six being a member of the airport
consultative committee okay yeah we've
been on it I'd suck
that's the ward yeah I'm also a member
of the airport consultative committee
although I shall be not taking part in
any of the discussions I'll generate
thank you I remembers just before we get
started on the list there's an addendum
that's been published that relates to
all the items were considering tonight
you know just be assured that members
have received that and had a chance to
digest the contents thank you the items
that we've got before us tonight are
quite significant items we do have
speakers as well so I might be a little
bit harsher on people wanting to keep
coming back to raise new points so if
you're going to speak please take that
opportunity and make sure you clearly
explain all your or all your views and
issues thank you so first of all we have
item number six which is a new airport
terminal building London Southend
Airport
as members will see that the aerial
image here just gives some context the
application site you'll see the airport
term position centrally and the airport
the new terminal building is as
highlighted here at this stage in the
development on this image
it just shows a small a small element of
the building that's on the site at the
moment and that's the part of the
building that was first granted consent
and an outline back in 1997 we can take
you to the location plan
so on this plan members will see the
outline of the airport in its entirety
except for the poor boundary here
outlined in blue the application is
relating to these out areas edged in red
to the north and to the south of the new
terminal building see here that the
building has increased in size from the
aerial image and this includes
extensions that were granted back in
2012 take you to the photos of the
existing building this just gives you
some existing images of the building
taken recently right so this is the
southern elevation the building has a
curved roof form with a glazed frontage
and an overhanging canopy and then has
small single-story elements to the south
and to take you to the next image please
clear and this is the building frontage
can I teach the first image as well
please and then this is the northern
aspect of the existing building which
also has this single-story element the
proposal is to demolish the single-story
elements to the north and the south
elevations this is the one to the north
here and replace these again with single
storey elements but larger in scale can
take you to the proposed elevations now
so this image that centrally shown here
shows the existing two-story building
you'll see all these uprights here a
part of the canopy projection to the
front elevation and then this this
extension here is to the north elevation
and this extension to the south the one
to the Lord is more substantial and than
the one to the south is proposed we can
just zoom into the image in the top
left-hand corner so this is the side
elevation of the North elevation and it
shows that the single-story proposed
extension would have a curved roof form
following that of the main building if
you can go over to the other side
elevation please the extension to the
southern boundary which is smaller an
extent would have a different form it
would have a flat-roofed parents there
the extensions are proposed to increased
capacity of baggage reclaim and for
additional space for screening of
baggage the extension to the southern
elevation is to comply with European
regulations which come into force next
September and it will apply to all major
airports if I can take you to the
proposals map can give you a bit of
context its relation to the planning
policy so the site and the terminal
building is positioned here is within
the area allocated in the joint area
action plan for development within the
airport's boundary and its environs you
will note that the airport in the main
falls within the Rochford district and
this is the the district boundary is
this black line running along here so
the south end district is to the south
and the airport's runway extension was
dealt with by Southend Borough Council
it was the runway extension consent
issued in 2011 subject to section 106
legal agreement which limited the number
amongst other things the
of passengers to a maximum of two
million per annum a central principle of
the joint error action plan is that the
airport can expand its operations to
enable this number of passengers to be
carried policy tf1 of the joint error
action plan specifically relates to
planning applications for expansion of
the new terminal building and is
supportive of such the proposed building
comply with sustainability criteria in
our local policies and can meet the
briam standard of excellence and subject
to feasibility and its there is a
condition requested for such the site is
within flood zone 1 which is that the
least risk of flooding and development
is therefore considered acceptable in
principle given the scale of development
proposed it is considered necessary to
impose a condition to require a detailed
surface water drainage strategy to be
agreed prior to commencement of the
development so the development wouldn't
be able to start until that was that was
all agreed this is to ensure that
surface water runoff did not exceed an
agreed rate the applicants would also be
required to undertake some archeological
investigation in relation to this
northern end of the site the
recommendation chairman is one of
approval subject to the conditions are
stated and as noted on the addendum
Thank You members huge rant say on that
which is which is good I'm quite happy
to go straight to the recommendation
printed on 615 with the relevant change
as mentioned in the addendum so on that
basis members in favor please indicate
okay thank you
yes unanimous that's fast item seven
land to the north of London Road and
south of roars Lane and west of Ross
Industrial Estate roar of flame Rayleigh
yeah chairman this is an application
sorry
so chairman this is an application for
the proposed strategic landscaping in
association we face one of the
development approved for up to 500
dwellings by outline Planning Commission
atlanta north of london road and south
of world flame bailey in 2016 so as you
see here it's that the northern area of
that extent it does exclude a couple of
parcels here as well from this
particular application but the wider
site sends all the way down to london
roads part of the outline application
it's already been approved the plan to
please so they're intended to be three
phases of development at the site
therefore this place is just the first
phase which is a northern area
immediately south of Oliver lanes and
this area and here the site consists of
open land with some existing trees and
some hedge row on the warplane boundary
there was also a reserved matters
application pending consideration for
the detailed design of 192 dwellings
representing phase one however this is
not yet before Council for consideration
so the strategic landscape impose
incorporates five landscaped zones we
have a link road corridor which is
through the center here and we've got a
footpath if we can try and see if we can
zoom in on that central area thank you
so here we've got footpath in the
cycleway on the eastern side and then on
the western side and we've got footpath
and as you can see this wire also
running through this area and there's
various collection of street trees we've
also got a gateway landscape along the
roar-off lane so we can go up a little
bit you have look at that so this is
about 20 to 30 meters of landscape strip
all along this voltage here and it also
have it's gonna be about 1.5 meters in
height and worth of earth shaping and
again we've got sort of swolled feature
coming through here as well and the
east-west corridor so if we go down to
the central green section so this is
called the northern strategic east-west
corridor because the central green which
includes the main area open space it's
also going to have a children's play
space from the centre there it's gonna
have a village green type character
we're planting and management part
semi-natural and part urban park within
the western landscape corridor so that's
to the far west whole section here again
a good level rule looking landscape and
post here and he's restricting height
landscaping here but overhead lines and
power lines we've got a network of
recreation parks all running through
this area a woodland copse as well as in
this particular area here
well as you can see we've got the
attenuation basins to the north and to
the south in this particular section
so the key material considerations are
landscaping open and play space noise
surface water drainage highways public
right away in ecology with regards to
landscaping large majority of the
landscaping would be entirely new the
site be mostly an open field in
character with the retention of some
trees and remnants of some hedgerow
the council's arborcoat list it's not
object to the principle of the scheme
more hedgerow corridors are consider to
be acquired and this is controlled by
the condition that we've imposed there
are two trees proposed for attention
that were required to be removed within
the outline application these will still
require a removal to ensure they do not
conflict with the visibility to place of
the access so they're roughly
there and that location of here a hecho
that was shown to be retained within the
outline to the north eastern boundary
will also need to be included for
retention within the strategic
landscaping plan controlled by condition
so that's roughly in this area here will
be asking for a particular hedgerow to
be retained with regards to open and
play space so the current application
has a play space located within the
center is it pointed out early just in
that area that's going to provide space
to accommodate a local will equipped
area of play if were to propose in this
position on the site the overall size of
the central green exceeds that shown on
the parameters plan for the outlined
application we've regards to noise the
current application does link to the
noise mitigation requirements as it
shows the landscaping arrangement which
would need to include earth funding the
council's Environmental Services
Department is not concerned on the basis
of the information provided which shows
an initial overview of the intended
noise mitigation full details of the
heightened profiling of the earth Bund
shown along the Gateway landscape a Long
Wharf Lane so along the front here and
also along the eastern edge which are
proposed in relation to road traffic
noise will be dealt with through
conditions attached the approved outline
application we've got the surface water
drainage the strategic landscaping
scheme submitted currently shows the use
of swales and attenuation basins these
are inaccessible locations from a design
perspective there is a slight difference
between the plans submitted as part of
the details for discharge of containers
details the outline application the
strategic landscaping plan however this
can be addressed by condition highways
and public rights away during the course
of the application a footpath estar
being providers to the east of the
proposed school site as sort by county
highway so that's running along this
eastern edge here this was excluded from
the original outline as consumers
initially raised by County Education
however they have now removed their
objection count Essex bridle eyes
association has requested that a
brighter access to be provided for the
western green corridor so along this
area here however when consulting
current county public rights-of-way
they're not supportive as such a bride
away as it would not connect to any
question accessible public rights-of-way
to the south and to the north
it only link to the plot and bridle ways
the majority of which are not publicly
maintained by aurora flame which is
considered to be an unsafe connection as
are a safety concern
it is not appropriate for this
development of why the bridal race
thought it's considered ecology so for
the accountancy ecology recommends a
further condition being posed requiring
further so they work to be undertaken
prior to works commenced in this part of
the current application however based on
the survey work undertaken as part of
the outline application and since that
time by the developer such a condition
is not considered reasonable mitigation
related to great crested newts remains a
requirement of the outline application
since this report an addendum were
produced we have also received a
landscaping briefing from countryside
which was forwarded by countryside to
members on Tuesday this provides a brief
summary of their landscaping concept as
part of this application it's not
necessary for members to have viewed
this prior to reaching a decision on
this application chairman this
application is recommended for approval
subject to a condition which is also
shown amended on the addendum thank you
some hands this time I think that's the
Stanley no just walk out standing okay
just turn that microphone off please say
first of all that the site is actually
not ready but Rory when it comes under
Roy's Parish Council I know you spoke
back boys like the next thing is where
is the water intending to go as you know
that the site what we're looking at the
moment easy Zone two I believe and there
are different levels of the way the site
is it falls back into the Royal if
Industrial Estate and on to Roy flame my
concerns are with the retaining of water
from those and pulling it round to the
number four pond or pond number four
which is actually joining into pond one
I'd like to know if the officers have
gone to the right parent own
of the rorish brook in in places where
they are the right parent owners and if
the counts were spoken to them as this
site was already known to flood on the
first instance this came to counsel and
was rejected on the basis of tidal
locking and and flooding with because it
hasn't got the infrastructure there how
do you mitigate that tidal locking in
relation to your disposing of water from
pond one and other ponds these plans as
I say were refused because of tidal
locking and those comments were made by
councillor Keith Hudson Hudson when he
was here and he involved at that time I
want to know if any consultations have
been with Roy parish flood alley Action
Group as they have very up-to-date
calculations on that area that we're
talking about and as the inspector was
invited in the first instance on the
first planes that were put in but was
then told that the council refused it
and then it was reapplied for could you
tell me why we haven't asked the
inspector to revisit the site as you
know that the we all don't believe in
raw reef and we don't know too much
about raw if and what its criteria is
are the flood plain in the raw if the
Walter floodplain our table is a high
table water table and any more water
coming off of the lamed and that will be
concrete paths whatever it is will be
coming in to Rory at a faster rate as we
have said in our document
the strategic flood risk assessment if
you haven't read it I suggest you read
it because it's very good for
information and the brook is now
somewhat a little bit smaller than what
it is supposed to be yeah you might know
if it's great fun this cancer Stanley if
you address the chair please
yeah he's addressing me and it's it's
there 25% smaller than what the brook
was originally so I wonder if there is
any mitigation being done by the
developer in not only the upstream which
would then affect lower which would then
affect a laburnum way or downstream
where we're deposited in the water too
and also could you tell me what the time
lapses of the of that water flow also
the I notice that the developer has
identified nine sites of where water is
discharged from the land from from the
pipes are they going to have the valves
gate valves that that is in their
document here as well as the ones from
the ponds there are several other items
here I've got sixteen in all and just to
let you know that it's considered by
common law that you can't take more off
the land and what is necessarily coming
in so in other words if if you've got so
many liters arriving you can't dispose
of any more than what is what is
arriving and that's I think that's well
well-documented it's it's we having on
pages 21 5.6 at page 8 3.2 15 up to 17
page 19 five point one and point two out
of the strategic
flood risk assessment and I think they
come into play in this circumstance I
think that it would be nice for the
planners to meet with other agencies
like the flood action group and and I
think this also needs to be scrutinized
a little bit more carefully than just
waving it through thank you Thank You
councillor Stanley there's a couple of
things that you mentioned I just need to
sort of make a couple of points you you
you mentioned about visiting riparian
owners that's not a necessary thing for
the planning permission to be determined
you've also mentioned a number of
technical issues which again on
absolutely necessary foot for this I
will point you towards one D on the
recommendation which clearly says about
the drainage scheme and what it has to
be that the the detail of it has to be
two particular drawings and then for
point one on page seven point seven
Essex County Council lead Florida
Authority lead local flood authority we
are happy with the conditions placed on
the outline permission so don't have any
specific comments so I do think that in
in listening to you I do need to make
sure that that point is is is really
clearly made councillor Wilson
you indicated any other members
indicating at the moment Thank You chef
at paragraph 4.1 role with parish
council said that the access to the site
is only going to be through roth line
and they're concerned about conflicts of
construction traffic with the day to day
traffic and that's that's overruled at
paragraph 516 because it's saying that
it would be unreasonable for the spine
right to be
put in place art the way that I
understand is what Roth parish counts
are saying is that they don't want any
vehicles doing rights it says in effect
to lube having said that this it might
not be viable to put the spine Road in
at this stage there are other ways that
you could provide that that access so
it's not necessarily building the road
itself but you can have temporary Road
services that would allow that is that a
reasonable condition to put on the
developer because the Newport thank
chairman and the officer said on the
western side there was a noise
attenuation noise mitigation measure for
highways noise I'd like to know if the
noise from the Industrial Estate has
been taken into account for that and I
also know that from what I could see
there's nothing about air quality in in
this report and we're there any measures
have been put in for there wouldn't be
anything about air quality strategic
landscaping all right okay so um what
I'll just
I'm stick with the noise from the
Industrial Estate then Thanks I believe
that's where the Bund is just to briefly
come back on sunny she's raised so far
so with regards to the drainage side of
things and we have a condition as part
of the outline Planning Commission which
requires a lot of detail to be submitted
and agreed in relation to drainage
matters on the sites that detail which
is quite substantial we've already had
in and we are currently considering it's
not something that we're looking at in
detail this application it's something
that's been looked at separately as part
of the approved outline application so
this is just looking at the landscaping
and obviously showing the attenuation
basins it's part and parcel of showing
the sort of landscaping with the
strategic element we've got a face on at
the moment so it's it's not something
that's being considered now but it is
something that is being considered as
part of the discharge
process with regards to the construction
traffic and we do again there's a
condition on the outline Planning
Commission which requires a construction
management plan to be agreed as part of
that application to do is how they will
deal with sewage deliveries access that
kind of thing so we can certainly
mention this it's an option it's not
something that we could deal with as
part of this application and because
it's part of the original outline
application and construction management
plan requirement but it's something that
we can perhaps speak to the developer
about as part of that application the
wider outline and the condition that
we've got imposed onto that already
the noise mitigation and it's the
highway traffic noise specifically the
industrial estates concerns will come
later with the wider phasing of the
development as far as the noise
mitigation details we have our so far I
don't know if that assists you'd like to
come back to Stanley
outside thank you
with regards to the footpath that we
make sure which is heavy which is oddly
as we look at it on the left-hand side
of the industrial unit is there any
footpath that is going to be put in on
Rory flame
leading around to that area and do we
have a crossing of any description for
the children that will actually come
from the properties on the other side of
Rory flame I know that that element
isn't part of this this application no
again is something we've got so just
checking with my colleague actually
because she dealt with the outline
application it's again an outline
application condition which required a
crossing I'm over the road it's not part
of this application but it will then
connect up with this footpath as well so
it will connect with the footpath we've
got a footpath at the front in front
edge of this side
no we zoom in on this there isn't
intended to be a footpath on this side
but the footpath would come out extend a
little way and bit the crossing be
approximately there
just the microphone again please forgive
me for asking but the the occupants of
the properties do not cross over in the
access road to the Industrial Estate
they cross over employ flame and and buy
such that they've got cross over from
the left side or the right side of the
lane cross over and walk along the path
now if the pathway is only part way on
their entrance to the Industrial Estate
where we've got the eastern edge there
that that seems to defeat the object of
the path because if it past stops there
think they can't literally sort of go
anywhere if you haven't got a path then
surely that's got to come with the plan
and suppose a pathway you've got 500
airs he's going up there and you've got
skull meet what they supposed to walk on
thank you
chairman there was where Katie with
shame of regards to the eastern edge so
there will be a footpath coming along
north lane wrapping around this edge
which is not part of this application so
we're not coming the path of land to the
right up there which is part of the
outline application sort of part of this
consideration but there will be a path
that runs all the way along down that
edge and then links in with the footpath
that is shown within this application as
well is that helping order
[Music]
along all the western edge you mean okay
so we're looking at the the define site
within the redline we're looking there's
the strategic landscaping within that
obviously there are concerns about the
footpath but that's outside of the
actual application site I I can't a car
I can't speak for how things were
interpreted there that's we've we've got
a recommendation as I say for the
outline strategic layout on this first
third of the site obviously they'll be
more to come as the things go there are
conditions slightly amended poem printed
on page six of the addendum which point
towards the further detail and
conditions and additional work that
still needs to be done within this but
it's just the basic outline the
strategic outline that we're looking at
here so members based on that and the
discussion we've had those members in
favor of the approval please indicate
okay thank you very much that item is
carried we go on to next item eight
which is land between star lane and
Alexandra Road south of High Street
great Wakering
chairman so just to give some context to
the apps to the site we have star lane
down here and then the main high streets
in great Wakering and the site that
we're talking about is is this area here
roughly with the ponds just lying
outside of the application site boundary
to the south you can take you to the
proposal map expert please
so members will note that this
application site relates to an allocated
site for residential development
released from the Greenbelt under policy
ser 9b
the site has outlined planning
permission granted in 2016 for
residential development for up to 180
units in this application the principle
of residential development the quantum
and other matters to do with flood risk
in ecology were all considered as well
as access to the site this application
before you tonight seeks approval for
reserve matters relating to access
appearance layout landscaping and scale
I can take you to the character areas
so 180 dwellings are proposed across the
site as a whole and in response to a
conditional requirement on the outline
for a design code the applicants have
proposed three different character areas
in order to the dwellings on the site
provide some variety in terms of the
appearance and the scale and the massing
so you'll see that there's one character
area here as shown in green and then
another small area of similar types of
dwellings in this area here towards the
west the there's a yellow character area
and then a purple and it's spread across
the site there's a mix of two three four
and five bed houses proposed as well as
one bed flats the variety in terms of
the architecture I'll show you when I
take you to the elevations in a second
there are 17 different housing types
proposed a mixture of 2 and 2.5 stories
could I take you to the heights massing
plan please cur so across the site this
gives you an idea of where the higher
properties are proposed these are only
2.5 stories and they're shown in the
sort of burgundy color and the remainder
are largely two-story which is orange
with only one single storey bungalow
proposed just there the other yellow
[Music]
development you can see is garage again
a single-story the maximum Ridge height
on the site is nine point six meters
width but many of the properties are low
at around 8 meters to the ridge there's
a mixture of houses and flats the two
flatted blocks are provided one provided
here and one provided just there where
dwellings back onto existing neighboring
residential developments that's along
the northern boundary and perhaps the
best showing you on the site layout plan
please Claire its number
this is a colored image so we're on the
boundaries were the site a joint
existing residential development resist
a substantial sort of landscape buffer
there and the separation distances
between the existing and proposed
dwellings is in excess of what the Essex
design guide seeks and we say is
acceptable the relationship between
dwellings on the site is also considered
acceptable and in the main the one meter
side separation the councils policy is
achieved as would minimum plot widths be
achieved all the houses would meet the
council's garden area standard and the
two only the two flatted blocks which
are here and here would be provided with
communal space which is in line with how
the council would usually seek to
achieve residential amenity space for
such they would fall slightly under the
provision but the policy does allow for
consideration of the wider environment
and the proximity to other green and
open spaces within the site and on this
particular occasion that's slight
shortfall it's considered acceptable new
structural plantings proposed along the
northern boundary here and then the main
open green space provided centrally
within the site that would have a swale
running through it as part of the suds
features and this area of the open space
would also be a depression attenuation
pond also linking into that sustainable
urban drainage system the master plan
landscaping strategy if I could take to
that please Claire
it's further down towards the bottom
actually
so this has been developed and sets out
an approach to the landscaping and
positioning of trees but the there is a
requirement on the outline that specific
details of the precise tree planting
along Street corridors and within the
open spaces is provided so that would
all all that detail would come in
relation to that conditioner to later
stage again can I take you to the
parking layout please so parking across
the site would be compliant with the
council's policy and on this plan what
is highlighted because largely the
houses have on plot parking for the Accu
pious this is this just shows the
visitor parking which is again in
compliant with the standard and it shows
that it is you know pet the potted
across the site so and visitors can pull
into these lay-by is perhaps visiting
properties or utilizing the public open
space around vehicle access to the site
would be from star lane so to the south
with an emergency access provided north
this northern axis would be a pedestrian
link though so providing ready through
route to the high street and the
facilities there for residents can I
take you to the street scenes please so
there are 17 different house types
proposed and said in the terms of
materials and finishes there is a quite
a wide variety proposed some rendering
weather-boarding brickwork this gives
you an impression of some of them
without taking you through every
individual house on the site so this is
one of the typical streets that this is
the street scene here again largely
two-story quite traditional in scale and
form pitched roofs some gable ends and
small dormers set into the roof space
policy compliant and what the Essex
design guide seeks to achieve there is
another section of street scenes maybe
just to show you
whew another indication of what the
scale and the appearance of those
dwellings would be all the dwellings
have space to store refuse bins close to
the heart and enable the residents to
take those bins to the highway for
collection usually stored in in rare
Gardens in only a couple of cases
occupants would be required to drag
their bins slightly further to the
highway in the rounds given the scale of
development process is considered
reasonable it would still be readily
achievable by those occupants overall it
is considered that the detailed layout
and design is to a high standard and
meets council standards the
recommendation chairman is one of
approvals subject to the published
conditions speakers on this cancer
Science Council
yeah it's all good five minutes I'm the
chairman of a Parish Council and please
say the wimpy did look at lots of the
comments that came through on the
Atlanta mission and they have moderated
their design one point in the officer's
report point two point two report says
that Stanley and brick works total
number was 116 in fact is 119 there was
a modification to do with the pumping
station section 106 parish counts have
not been consulted over section 106
needs for great Wakering and these have
been decided by some higher authority
with no regard to those living in the
area and in fact an awful lot and money
is being spent in South in Borough
Council's areas enhancing roundabouts
etc what we have a particular problem is
the country path which from the mini
roundabouts the north end of star lane
to own tree cottages which is about four
hundred and thirty-five meters a country
path east seems to be a verge which gets
cut occasionally and it's difficult to
walk even
normally because you can't see where you
help you put new feet and you've got
cars running by the side of you if you
trip you could fall over and get run
over and women with young children live
in those cottages and they are seen
frequently they have no alternative but
to run walk the buggies up the road and
they can't possibly get off the road if
a car comes along so they're taking
their life in their hands that is where
the section 106 money should be spent
not on roundabouts in South Limburg
right okay um the proposed change is
also to do with 106 has anyone checked
that the changes proposed for the high
street are actually practical because
we've had simple simmer for the trouble
previously we do news there was
something proposed to do to the curbs
when it came out it was totally
impractical and the money just got
wasted so money that could have gone to
Wakering got lost the wildlife many
trees on the outline plan seemed to
disappear from the north edge of the
ponds if you look at the outline plan a
lot the bottom net the ponds are not
just ponds that they're a wildlife site
in the outline plan there was dense
trees along that line that's disappeared
so now you've almost got the road a
little bit of grass and it just falls
into the wildlife time while my site
should be protected not exposed to
children playing with balls and things
there's no sign in the present document
that the Essex Wildlife site or in that
tree England have been approached a lot
this change in fact natural england say
that they should be approached if there
is a are any changes but this just seems
to be floating through
and one good point is we've been having
lots of trouble with fly tipping with
the access road but potato wimpy you're
going to have a whole gate delivered
soon which we hope will help
Thank You chair and good evening
counselors um firstly I must correct um
my name is Samuel Caslon but I'm
actually at a Planning Manager at Taylor
Wimpey London not the agent we are
immensely proud of the scheme that you
are considering this evening and it
truly is a result of collaborative
working between ourselves
the council's statutory consultants as
well as extensive consultation with the
local community a number of
pre-application meetings have been held
with the Parrish district and County
Council to ensure that the scheme is of
the highest quality the application
began life in 2014 when the council
allocated the site for housing in its
site allocations document following
extensive consultation this was followed
up in 2016 with an outline application
for 180 homes before which extensive
pre-application
consultation with the council and oh
sorry of which 63 homes ought to be
affordable the consent was subject to a
section 106 agreement which will see 1
million seven hundred and seventy one
thousand six hundred and seventy two
pounds paid by the applicant towards
education and health provision to be
spent in great Wakering we do not feel
it is appropriate to revisit the legal
agreement at this stage and the council
have not sought any additional funds of
course we are happy to continue our
dialogue with the parish council and
I've mentioned as well to councillor
Sawyer that where there are any
maintenance issue we will see to have
informal discussions about how we can
assist with any of those the application
before you tonight deals solely with
fixing the detail the house types the
layout and overall design before
embarking on the final scheme extensive
discussions began with officers and
councillors to the shape of the final
design officers are now assess these
detail details as have the council
statutory consult ease who have no
objection to the final proposals to this
end officers are now able to recommend
approval in doing so the officers
confirm that the details fully meet the
council policies this being in relation
to the design garden sizes of parking
etc
the comments made by the parish council
are acknowledged and understood we have
made every effort to engage with the
parish councillors at each stage and
provided them with hard copies of the
application documents the regards to
parking each house is owned off street
parking of at least two spaces per unit
and some forty-five spaces are provided
throughout the site with regards to
wildlife we have been in dialogue with
Natural England and their response to
the application is also in the officer's
report and they have no objections to
our proposals councillor soil is correct
we have been working engaging with the
parish council and we are looking to
beef up our security on-site and with
regards to fishing lights and also
working with the fishing clubs that use
the site as well to ensure that the
gates are locked regular we have now
built over 100 new homes as part of the
first phase at great Wakering employed a
vast number of people ocol people in the
process we hope to Taylor Wimpey have
fully demonstrated how seriously we take
our commitment to managing the
construction stage in order to be the
best possible neighbours to existing
residents where issues have arisen
we have been quick to respond and
rectify them we hope to continue to
build on the work we have completed so
far and great Wakering and continuing to
invest in the local workforce thank you
for your time and I look forward to
listening to your debate visiting
members wish to speak as the queues
good evening now being a local resident
being brought up in that great weight
Krynn going to the school and going to
King Edmonds I've seen some change it's
some good some bad be amount of new
properties that have been built in our
area is bad we've got a lack of school
places a lack of doctors the traffic is
bad
residents moment in all the time which
you can understand when these residents
have moved into Wakering they moved to a
village but the village isn't the
village to no more it's now becoming a
town I'm not happy nor a residents happy
about another 180 homes we're also not
happy with what's happened recently it's
been this week with them clearing some
rubbish along its way Curran High Street
there's been continuously mud on the
road this week yeah there's been
continuously mud on the road this week
traffic being held up all week is this
the start of what residents have got to
put up with again now this should have
been happening post 2020 but now we've
got to look forward to this all
happening the game also I would like to
know where all the 106 money's going
this time because we never seem to get a
correct answer to where the 106 money's
going and it would be nice if we could
tell residents this time where it's
actually going to also could I ask why
so many trees have been removed and what
type of trees are we replacing because
this does affect the wildlife again also
I did speak to Taylor Wimpey
about trying to make it a little bit
more friendly this time with making it
with Hedgehog friendly which on the
reports doesn't seem to have been
mentioned at all yes that right no no
sorry no and also the other thing is
about the park as well we was told we
was going to be having X amount of money
allocated to the park
and I can't see that in anything either
at the moment and also the other things
that I'm not happy about is I can't seem
to find the reports the archeological
advice report can die elsewhere that is
place and also there is another report
that we can't seem to find condition 18
is the local flood authority they should
have been a report for that which I
can't seem to find and I can't seem to
find anything else but I probably I've
got a list of things I could come back
to thank you
Thank You chairman hmm yes I'd also like
to emphasize we we have had a number of
meetings with Taylor Wimpey at parish
and also district councillors and the
last meeting that we we held with them
there they will seem to be an agreement
that they were they had intended to have
a children's play area on sites we
suggested that perhaps it would be
better for the wider community if the
money that they were looking to invest
in that was was actually allocated to a
much broader scheme at the Recreation
Ground and that seemed to be agreeable
we also had counsel appearing at that
meeting portfolio holder for environment
who was also agreeable to that
suggestion but again there doesn't seem
to be anything in the report to say that
there is s106 money allocated
specifically for that my concern is that
if there's no legal agreement for this
money to go forward as part of this
arrangement it may never happen and just
stop you there for a moment the content
of the section 106 agreement is not part
of what would determine
tonight that's part of a separate a grip
a rain formal legal agreement outside of
this decision and is probably best taken
up with officers in another place if you
don't move I mean in the report it does
mention about some gas plant apparatus
which is within the vicinity of the site
and there was some concerns from the the
the National National Grid that there
was if this site might have any impact
on their apparatus there doesn't seem to
be any response as to saying whether
there is any impact and what mitigation
might might be needed if there was an
impact so I've wondered if there's any
information about that we've regard to
the archeological advice as well from
Essex County Council they in the report
they there's a piece in there that says
that they were seeking some information
and they don't think think that they've
had all the information that these
required and if they're the statement
goes that the archeological condition
has not been discharged at this point so
wondered if there's any further
information about that with regard to
the Essex County Council as the leader
blood authority in relation to condition
18 because the the flood the flood
strategy has changed from the original
plan that was brought out line which we
we were actually this was part of our
air suggestions the parish in and
district councillors which we're pleased
about the change but Essex County
Council seem to have some questions over
the flow rates in relation to the new
strategy
and there doesn't seem to be any any
information as to whether they've been
satisfied with that as well as has been
mentioned in relation to the the traffic
going onto sites we've we've had
experience from phase one in relation to
vehicles accessing the site and then
then going off site as well we've had
quite number and this is this has been
obviously an issue mostly in the winter
time in the spring time but it is an
issue all year round that number of
debris has been brought onto the public
highway for off from the sites and
perhaps we might be looking to have a
condition so that there's a proper
management scheme ins and and
appropriate will wash in facilities for
vehicles access in this phase to section
of the application thank you point you
in a couple of direction when the
outline permission was granted there
were a number of conditions those
conditions are not fully discharged at
this point particularly in 4.42 with
regard to the archaeology four point
seven with regard to the flooding and
four point five with regard to the
traffic from highways those conditions
need to be discharged before the
development takes place at this point
the developments not ready to start as
yet this is a step on the journey with
the focus on the particular areas of
access appearance layout and scale
I'm sorry counts the Hugh's
cancel mrs. Howe just wants to ask Katie
does it meet our visitors amount of
visitors parkings young reason I'm
asking because I'm 4.1 wait wait Queen
council is saying it's short by 45 I
just wanted you to confirm that it
doesn't meet the parking
point two five perdy so they do meet
this department
okay thank you they're members we have a
recommendation printed on page eight
point two eight item seven with various
conditions can ask those members in
favor of approval to please indicate
thank you
we now move on to 11 West Street
Rochford her deferred item from last
month should've been in turn referred
from the weekly list this is in two
parts the next application is listed
building and concern this one is about
the principal so chairman this
application is for Planning Commission
for the conversion of Atherton change in
use of the King's Head public house into
11 bed sets and three shop units the
building is located within the town
center of Watford so in this location
yeah
and has a frontage we can talk to the
market square oh yeah thank you the
building is great too listed and there
was also a tandem application for
considerations tonight Felicity building
percent the building has been empty to a
couple of years members may recall
previous application at this site for
twelve bed sets and one small shop
community which was refused on the
grounds at the proposed loss of the
ground-floor commercial premises within
this important Town Center location
would an adverse impact on a commercial
vitality of Watford town center the
tandem application of the listed
building percent at this time was
approved members may also recall an
application by the same developer at 22
South Street which was approved in
February to convert based on offices
into 12.6 this was also a listed
building the residential use of this
building has now commenced
so the existing building consists of the
public ground floor level and then a
four bedroom dwelling of first row level
the front part of the ground-floor will
be converted into three shop units which
would utilize our to existing entrances
here from the main road one of these
intricacies will also provide access for
upper floor bed sits the rear part of
the building will contain four bed since
they've got these in this location here
the shop units would have floor spaces
of sixteen point eight nineteen and
twenty point five two square meters the
council's economic development team
consider the inclusion of these
commercial units would have a positive
impact on the vitality of the watch for
Town Center having objected to the
previous application
a new access will be provided to the
rear so in this location here and that
would be inter bedsit for with the
enlargement of existing window opening
and within the courtyards of this area
here we would have a door formed into
bedsit 3
so the first floor would be converted
into seven bed sets there will be mine
external alterations to the rear corner
providing a fire escape access so in
this area here and a door opening to
bedsit 11 through the enlargement of an
existing window all bed six will include
an ensuite shower room allowing for
independent living the bed sits would
vary in size between eleven point eight
eight and twenty three point three one
meters squared this application was
deferred from the november development
committee meeting in order for the
applicant to look at concerns raised
relating to over development of the site
and insufficient evidence to support the
need for three commercial units and
compliance with the watch returned
center area action plan in response the
applicant has provided a supporting
letter along with a letter from the
neighbor to number twenty-two South
Street which provides clarity around the
issues raised within the last committee
these are referred to within the report
and the addendum council policy
including that within the watcher town
center area action plan supports retail
provision within the town centers this
proposal would therefore be compliant
with policy and the applicant is not
required to provide viability
information with regards to the three
units opposed if we tell you Cesar could
not be found for the unit so it's a
possibility that normally Tony's uses
could still reviewed favorably such as
offices or cafes however this would be
subject to a separate application viewed
on its individual merits it is officers
view that proposal would not represent
every development here but represents a
collection of small units for
residential and retail use they would
add to the vitality of Watford town
center since this report and addendum
were produced we have also received an
additional resident response which
states as follows I've just read it out
is the lessor response we don't know the
actual whilst we know the the the person
who's written it we don't have the
address so I can't provide you with that
but their letter says I apologize for
this late response but I have been
indisposed it is my considered opinion
that after living in Rochford since the
1930s this will be the last nail in the
flaky coffin and the destruction of
what's its character this began with the
erection of the hideous new buildings on
the North Street side of the square it
was not helped by the one large hitch
pomp next to and eclipsing the genuine
old stone wolf
the square has now lost its direction
completely with the failure of the local
police force as it has never become a
noble as it now become a no-go area in
the 1940s it was possible to hold
black-tie functions in the Delft cafe
virtually adjoining with its charming
windows and to parking a square now the
whole area has become depressed and
distressed with respectable adults
hesitant to visit after dark I have
already suggested that the square be
opened up to north street for better
access including buses all high density
development will do is to aggravate the
crumbling infrastructure of unbuilt but
promised schools dr. surgeries have yet
to appear and not always enforced every
effort must be made to restore the
king's head to its original function of
a community center this could help to
improve the amenities of the area of
which the square is the logical focus it
may also help to mitigate the gridlocked
roads it also provides a refuge to the
new developments on floodplains now
being built with entrance part running
downhill to ground floors of love level
the flood protection provisions are
wholly inadequate when the abnormally
high tides next come it is essential for
the reasons stated and your own material
policy considerations that this
application is not approved as it
constitutes a tearing out of Watford
sole the king's head must remain in
substance regardless of commercial
consideration however well-meaning
that's the contents of that letter
it remains officers view the proposed
the proposal meets with policy and this
application is recommended for approval
subject to the conditions listed within
the report and the addendum have two
speakers on this item
maximum five minutes
thank you I wanted to take the
opportunity just to have probably might
be five minutes but just to really set a
lot of summarizes they are newer to
building and as mentioned the owner of
22 South Street at the meeting a month
ago I think that there was a
representation so I probably didn't
explain in the right way with regards to
the retail space our original
application was declined because of
inadequate retail space on the ground
floor we've reviewed that and the whole
of the frontage of the building at
ground floor level is now for retail
space however is flexible accommodation
to suit the needs of retail occupier as
to whether they want the whole space or
three individual units that can be
adapted to suit whatever is needed
within Rochford or comes to the market
the other point that was raised was with
regards to the viability of commercial
retail units obviously we can answer the
question of viability of retail units
but what we have done as we put in our
supporting letter who has done some
research with some local commercial
agents who have informed us that there
is a demand for smaller retail space for
small to medium businesses and as such I
can't remember the door number I think
it's 25 but one of the vacant buildings
in West rate has just been led by Deb
man-grey on a five-year lease to an
expanding floristry business so they're
confident that they would be able to let
those units out to retail space coming
onto the the vacant building it has been
vacant for some considerable time and as
with 22 South Street we we've developed
that building and we own and manage that
building it's not something we've
developed and sold we managed to build
in and look after it
and maintain that we had terrible
problems when the building was at vacant
with regards to gangs and groups our
building being vacant
whilst being developed and unoccupied
was broken into on numerous occasions
damage was done within the building
there was a fire that was created in in
one of the outbuildings that affected
neighboring properties and the
supporting letter that you've heard from
the neighbor of twenty-two South Street
has been very pleased with the work that
we've done very plosive our conduct of
the work and very pleased that is now
occupied and the gangs and groups that
were around have now disappeared because
it's now an occupied building with
regards to the king's head that is
securely shuttered up and there was one
area which was a Velux window in the
roof and we had a call from one of the
neighbors and that's been broken into
recently where it's vacant and people
have climbed on the roof and and got in
and that buildings been vacant now for a
couple of years we're now working with
heritage they're very happy with what
we've put forward the the listed
building elements of what we're going to
retain within the building they're very
happy with the frontage of the the built
or the external of the building will
look no different to the Market Square
and as I say that we maintain and manage
the the building so it will bring what
is a listed building that's derelict and
open to vandalism back into use and life
and be maintained and looked after to
Heritage standards thank you for the
opportunity to speak have no more to say
thank you
and up to five minutes when you're ready
oh good evening and nice to see many of
you again firstly I would like to thank
the applicant for providing those
supporting documents and I welcome the
assurances that they did give regarding
their intentions about the management of
the property however I do think that
actually limited steps have been taken
which aren't any sufficient to address
the concerns expressed at the last
committee meeting which led to the
motion to defer on turning first to the
question of retail commercial space the
applicants herb as we just heard
presented an opinion from a local
property expert suggesting there would
be significant interest in the retail
units proposed on the ground floor this
is good as far as it goes obviously if
no unit so there I'd much rather they
were occupied rather than vacant but it
kind of begs the question to me which I
sort of raised last time if there is a
demand for retail and commercial space
in the Squared and how can the loss of a
large portion of the ground-floor
to residential use be justified policy
free of the town center action plan
seems clear on this point it says that
such a loss in the secretary shopping
frontage is justified only where it does
not have a detrimental impact on the
viability of the town center and where
it provides an alternative use likely to
contribute to the overall offer of the
area I've yet to hear any argument that
suggests the proposed inclusion of four
bedsit units on the ground-floor meets
these criteria by contrast it would
appear to me to the track from the
commercial offer an attractiveness at
the market square which is why several
nearby businesses of rejected proposal
and I carmody see why no committee would
approve an application on this basis it
was noted in the Economic Development
Officer pointed out the need for
start-up business space in this district
in that case it seems more appropriate
to retain the entire ground floor for
commercial use
creating a hub for small businesses in
this kind of very prominent and historic
location within the town square and this
seems to be more in keeping with the
council stated vision for the area one
issue which I don't find out the winds
have addressed concerns over development
and the level of immediately provided at
the last meeting I I cited policy DM 35
of the local development framework
development management plan it states
the upper floors and shop of shops and
commercial premises in town centers can
be used for residential purposes but
crucially only when
the accommodation is self-contained and
provides a satisfactory standard of
convenience in the MENA team for the
residents at the last meeting the
planning officer suggested it wasn't
relevant and the the m35 was designed
solely to ensure that residential units
had separate entrances from ground-floor
shops and with due respect I find it
difficult to accept that interpretation
for two reasons firstly the term
self-contained
when we're talking about accommodation
has a very clear meaning so in Section
two five four to 2004 Housing Act the
third part that definition states a
self-contained flat is one where a
toilet personal washing facilities and
cooking facilities are available for the
exclusive use of its occupants as we
discussed last time and come to the
current plan we can clearly see that bed
sits five and six on the first floor
share a bathroom accessed via a common
hallway this means likely did not meet
the statutory definition of
self-contained secondly policy the n35
refers to lead to provide a satisfactory
standard of residential convenience and
amenity noting again the shared bar from
four five and six and the lack of any
laundry facilities for residents in the
building in contrast to the development
on 22 South Street which need to provide
that facility extremely difficult to see
how the current plans meet this test
these issues could I think be addressed
by a less intense development of a site
with fewer residential units and I think
it's unfortunately that route hasn't
been chosen however at the moment I
think it's clear that the the policy
contravenes d and 35 in had asked the
committee to consider making a positive
commitment to providing accommodation of
a reasonable quality by rejecting the
current plans my final point at last
meeting concerned the impact of recent
and proposed residential development in
a town center and the surrounding areas
on infrastructure and the apparent lack
of any key motive assessment of this
impact without repeating my comments on
these issues that exists and in
particular I know again Essex police
consider asked that the council consider
refusing the application for twenty two
South Street earlier this year on the
grounds hmos can produce an increased
fear of crime which would attract the
residential environment it's clear from
consultation responses that this
proposal has led to similar fears and I
ask that the views of residents here as
expressed in that most recent letter as
well should be respected in summary I
feel the proposal remains inappropriate
and unacceptable from a policy
perspective
it appears to directly contravene the
town center action plan as well as the
local development framework development
management plan
I don't know object to the development
on this site I don't object to that
including a residential element but I
would submit the compliance with council
policy demands that the proposed will be
rejected and the applicant asked her
think again about what what constitutes
appropriate development in this
important town center location thank you
Thank You chairman Chester couple points
with record city's application its its
ease and it states 411 bed seats in
paragraphs Haley says the proposal
represents an HMO which I I believe does
I think it's a contradiction here I
think this is a demonstrating that it
going back to the points with concerns
last time it's an over development of
the site it clearly can't fit 11 bed
seats in in the normal way if they are
sharing a bathroom at the very least
that's the first point the second point
is of my favorite one parking standards
Essex hours yeah game misquote their own
parking standard he says it may they may
be reduced in main urban areas and I
think he said what we remember that I'm
not disputing the fact what ratiza main
urban area but I I would just like
people to think about the word reduce he
doesn't say none it says may reduce I
think no parking spaces is wrong in this
area I could understand that required
maybe tree there may be fewer required
than the minimum and certainly I can see
the need that you might say as there's a
big park car park behind you may not
need visitor plate spaces that's very
tough but I think this nanny's going too
far and then I'd like to draw people's
attention to which I've now lost on the
addendum Essex County highways
suggestion regarding the cycle store of
the October 20 pages I have on page nine
point one of their recommendation so
they suggested a recommendation is
regarding cycle Park in this saying
cycle parking shall be provided in
accordance with the EPO a parking
standard the officers have decided that
Essex County highways are wrong to
recommend this this is one of the things
we keep being told as counselors we we
should we should do what statutory
counsel to say the statutory consul T is
saying there should be secures park
cycle storage within the site officers
are saying it's considered that
sufficient cycle parking is provided
within nearby a backplane car park well
I don't that's not that's there might be
sufficient pretty certain ease and
secured it's not appropriate for someone
to keep their cycle long term in a
public car park I think the officers are
wrong to ignore that recommendation from
Essex County highways thank you thank
you
[Music]
cancer Mountain Thank You chairman just
I agree with the the points that
counselor hoy was raising there on on
the matter of IVA development and the
concerns of over development out of the
officers respond to to that please in
relation to this idea that they're
self-contained units but they are not
self-contained units because they have a
shared bathroom just before they answer
there I do need to point out that we had
a previous application
it was refused but one of the grounds
for refusal wasn't over development so
by default that even though it was a
refusal the basis of this layout this
standard has tacitly had some approval
however difference between bed suits
flats don't go back there again please
so I think we regards to the bed sit and
flat discussion you know it is something
that we've obviously looks at with
previous applications and in 22 South
Street we also had a similar situation
yet that was also approved
I'm with the best bedsit scenario so
we've got a ground floor level they
there's some that have ensuite
facilities and therefore they don't
share a bathroom but then we do have
some a first hall level bit which are
more classified as a HMO so they are
sharing the bathrooms and it's not
uncommon to have small units of
accommodation and being converted like
this with ins or town center locations
into small small units of accommodation
and we it wasn't an issue that we
refused the application while previously
although it was deferred as part of the
formal application in terms of the
actual you see the bed set usages so I
don't think it's something that we could
raise an issue this time around as part
of this current consideration process
thank you
Thank You chairman this item was
deferred at the last application meeting
so that all counselors were able to meet
the applicants and voice their concerns
this never happened
it didn't take place however a letter
from the application applicants is
attached to the application which does
make their position more clear I still
feel this development be in the wrong
place and has have serious concerns
regarding the quantity of units supplied
for all so that the two of these units
have shared facilities not sure those
acceptable in this day and age I do
appreciate that there are no Penningtons
considerations at this application be
refused I also appreciate that the
desperate need for this type of
accommodation in their area and
potential cost savings at these might
bring they will be considerable should
this application be successful
I trust the priority be given to Roger
District residents and RTC have full
nomination rights that absolutely is not
relevant to this planning decision okay
the only last one word was a very
successful South Street development
thank you sorry I need to keep the focus
that cast a couple more just to say
chairman the overall design I understand
about using the commercial space to the
front of the building but I'm not aware
of any drawings or anything else that
we've seen because I think the design
and the presentation of those in what is
basically a listed building is very
important so I don't know if the
officers have any indications as to how
that might work appreciate them they
might be flexible because it would be
wildly right for a next application yeah
I know I think that's something that we
really needs is the seat yeah it's it's
a bit like I think what we're dealing
with in this application is the
principle of retail units the next
application we're dealing with what I
think isn't that not relevant to the
definition of retail units that's the
point I'm making but I accept them I
accept your points all right
councillor Stanley Thank You chairman in
the addendum page 8 we've got apart from
what we've listened to at the moment a
lack of bins storage and the internal
walls are not in keeping with the listed
building
concerns of this of the structure is is
what is what we've got there are we to
suppose that the internal walls are
coming down and this is going to be any
reconstructing internal walls and the
change to the listed building that's
next application the comment about bins
is from a resident but can we go
straight where what the provision is
Regulus forests or departments this big
building if you like and that's where
the big deal okay
hey counselor
Thank You chairman
hmm I'm very interested in councillor
Michael always comments in relation to
to parking in the psychic stories
because then remember at the last
meeting I raised the issue about parking
and was told that in a town center
development this was not relevant but
councilor Hoy's assessment of the the
actual wording in relation to the fact
that parking may be reduced in that area
may also look to say that that there may
be a requirement for something if that
this this development doesn't provide
anything and also as I say it's very
interesting in relation to the comments
we've regards to the the cycle storage
as well we haven't had a response about
that so I'd like to know why our
officers have determined that they want
to ignore Essex County Council's advice
thinking well just reiterate the point
that I made about the parking last time
some of us longer in the teeth members
have have been there on numerous
occasions expressing concerns about
parking in towns and locations and given
the drive towards sustainability being
directly on routes of public transport
for both buses and with it within very
short distance of a train station and
with public parking readily available
there just isn't a sustainable argument
against the need to provide parking
provision however mr. Thomas is very
good on bike stores
the bar by to the particular and we've
regards to the psycho storage and
because we are in a town center location
we wouldn't normally expect them to
provide a independence or cycle store
because of its close proximity to like
councillor Smith for saying that the
train station the bus bus points the the
recycle recycle stores as well within
the actual public car parks it's not
something that we would have any
strength in really imposing and trying
to get them to seek on the site I think
we'd have difficulties there and that's
why it wasn't put forward as part of the
recommendation members are listening to
be some wake bahía behind bicycles and I
won't say that I own seven bikes myself
but I do I I think if a member were
inclined it might be in order to put a a
recommendation forward around that area
possibly with the detail to be discussed
precisely with officers and what's
achievable at a later stage but to do
that yes
I'd like to put forward that proposal so
that we we go with a recommendation from
Essex County Council in relation to
provision of a cycle storage on-site
okay right Thank You members we've had a
debate we have a recommendation printed
on page nine point eight with an
addition of
just wanted regards to the cyclist or
it's this concerns that we would be
imposed in a condition which we don't
see how they could reasonably achieve on
the side in terms of the space that
we're currently working with if we
impose a condition they can't reasonably
achieve then it makes it very difficult
for them first actually discharge or
planning condition on that particular
condition as I don't see where the space
is to potentially accommodate at cycle
store we've been little area we're
working with castor hoc way does this
not go to to prove that perhaps this is
overdevelopment in relation to a number
of that our unit suppose if they can't
provide sufficient space for I think I
think it's a fairness if it's not
possible to discharge the condition then
we obviously don't want to create
unnecessary delay if this item is
approved but it would be appropriate if
officers came back to us if there are
very specific concerns over that item
and if necessary we revisit that item
singly at a later stage I think that's
that seems like a fair way
that's the Merrick we're focusing on
cycle score I wonder chairman whether we
might
deal with by way of an informative
weather that would be considered
adequate by members that's a Griffin
Thank You chairman I can't recall the
full details but I believe that Essex
County Council are sponsoring or um
helping to provide cycle storage to
various organizations I'm not sure if it
affects private properties on that
council hoc way you've put forward an
amendment and it's been seconded so we
will deal with that one first
so the options are that that item is
included or not I guess if it's not then
councillor Merrick suggestion that it's
attached as an informative mark might
stand so first of all on the amendment
to include cycle storage as a condition
those members in favor of that please
indicate okay those against okay that
condition is now attached so the
substantive approval those members in
favor of the approve one please indicate
those against that item is approved
could I ask for my vote against to be
recorded please yep we now have item 10
which is the listed building consent to
the same property that we have just been
discussing
it's a chairman this application is for
listed building consent for works of the
building to enable the change of youths
proposed members a reminder that mr.
building consent was granted previously
under a separate application for similar
works during a determination of this
application officers in the county
historic buildings advisor met with the
applicants on-site to discuss at length
the proposed conversion works and the
impact on the historic building inside
the building there are clear remnants of
the original layouts
however these been previously undermined
historic walls and features do survive
in parts however it is not propose to
significantly alter these where walls
are being removed these are 20th century
and fabric and are not considered
significant the main rooms would be
retained with each unit located within
the existing room areas the central
staircase would be retained the county
historic buildings dividers is not
objected the applications subject to
conditions which have been which are
present on the Office report the
building retains the appearance of
public house within the Conservation
Area and this would be retained in
future through through these proposals
since this report on addendum would
produce we have also received an
additional resident response from
five-cent Andrews Road - it states as
follows really I think the comments are
more applicable to the previous
application but they have been
registered apart this one
so I urge you to turn down this
application it smacks of Rahman ISM an
application to turn the punchbowl into a
family home as a fuse and I think this
application should be refused
the developers brought it as a par but
it should stay a pub there seems to be
no consideration given to parking and
trying to squeeze 11 units into these
sorry pub smacks of brief on the
developers so that's the further comment
that we've had back as with previous
application the recommend a
recommendation to members remains that
one of approval thank you that's the cut
mark can I go back to my original
question Jim can we give caste a couple
more a bit more information about what
don't look like after it's done so we
have a condition which scan which will
require details to be submitted and
agreed in terms a lot of the actual fact
we don't have an actual visual as to
what it will look like completes I mean
in terms of the front of the building
they're not planning to make any changes
apart from actually just repair work and
and maintenance how it works it's really
the change is mostly happening to the
back so the main changes are really just
this this top level here we've got a
very slight change here a fire escape
and here we've got the the door have
been inserted where there's a window and
here we're looking to slight changing
where they're going to create a new
accessing to a bedsit here and this area
will be rendered so we've got a
conditioned impose that will deal with
the details around discharging exactly
what those elements will look like thank
you but I'm not particularly she ate
what the office is saying but I think
there are concerns that as to I mean
there must be some change to the
frontage and I just wonder how far we
would go presumably this historic
buildings advisor as consented to this
so that's at least given me some you
know
can't comfort if you like but you know
as far as the town center is concerned
and listed building I think it's
important and I think the character of
what we have here in the character of
the town center itself bearing in mind
what we said earlier and some of the
letters needs to be the same because
it's not a historic town center square
so you know that's my concern chairman
and it's about retaining that character
thank you if it just point you to point
17 on 10.4 the historic buildings
conservation officer specifically says
would not object to the revised
application that's the hoc way you
probably did say this but I just I might
have missed it or didn't quite hear the
whole thing did you state that the
internal alterations were regard to the
existing walls they're relatively recent
changes nothing historic with to do with
the basic fabric of the building
yes it's 20th century and our historic
buildings Weiser has been in had a look
during the course if I think the
previous application and we're looking
at quite minor changes they're really
trying to work within the layout of the
existing room formats and we've
obviously some additional partitions
included and so we're not looking at an
awful lot of an impact on the actual
internal warning of the actual building
itself there's been some concerns raised
about the the upper floor which is not
part of this but in relation to that
structural integrity and none of none of
this should affect fact that in any way
and it's it's not something that we
would be dealing with as part of this
application it may be something that
comes up as part of the building control
and side of things but it wouldn't be
something that would be an issue as part
of this current application all that
we're aware of at the moment thank you
the are they the approval is printed on
10.5 as for those members in favor of
approval please indicate those against
okay thank you that item is approved
under 10 plus 9
that brings our meeting to an end thank
you very much